of course uh president biden is now  officially inaugurated it's been about  24 hours  uh still a lot of excitement in the air  and guess what american businesses are  starting to show  their excitement as well yeah check out  this ad  exciting news america in honor of the  inauguration of our  oldest president ever applebee's is  introducing our new  soft food spectacular half off all our  existing soft foods  like jello soups plus creamed corn  creamed spinach creamed nachos and  creamed baby back ribs  along with some brand new items like  broccoli smoothies  fiber yogurt and steak pudding yum  from four to 4 45 every day it's  applebee's greatest early bird special  ever  and that's